[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum hi ryan
hey michael good to have you here with
me uh
hey we're gonna get right into this
interview but uh just if you really
enjoy the podcast i'm asking you to
subscribe
write a review five stars would be great
um what are the handles ryan that could
follow us
inside if you caught on twitter inside
of you podcast on instagram and facebook
that's right you could watch on youtube
you could listen like you're listening
right now i hope you guys have had a
glorious week and you're doing
good stuff you're you're staying healthy
and and having a good time with this
thing called life um stick around
afterwards i'll uh read out the old
patreons those are part of the patron
family
and give you a lot of updates and stuff
about where you can see me some
conventions
and uh merch and all that great stuff
but right now this guy
has been in everything i mean
austin powers uh family guy robot
chicken
robot chicken can't hardly wait i mean
the list goes on you're gonna love this
guest he's a delight i love having him
on here let's just uh get into it let's
get inside
of seth green it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you look good thanks man i mean you look
like you have beach hair like a good
beach hair you know how your hair is
always good at the beach
all right yeah no i'll buy that i i'm i
haven't i haven't i don't spend a lot of
time at the beach
i'm being perfectly honest seth do you
by the way roaring fire for you and it
is not
coming together yeah it's nice though
look at that where are you is that your
living room
uh no we uh retreated to the mountains
you're in the mountains right now
yeah haven't quite got the big snow
that the weather's been promising but
it's it's been really quiet which is
nice
do you recommend leaving the house
because i really haven't left my house
other than a few things a week but
uh i could tell my anxiety is a little
through the roof lately
and uh do you do you get a little cabin
fever or
do you is that why you got out yeah well
we were in la all year
and we were in uh just extreme about all
of our covered precautions because
you know a lot of people got sick we
knew a lot of people that got sick it
was
it was [ __ ] crazy so we spent the
whole year
um working from home uh and
only venturing out in the smallest of
scales to get supplies when we needed
them and uh
we didn't really visit with anybody in
person until we had successfully over
eight or nine months confirmed what we
believed was a
a dependable bubble
right right so by the time it got to
christmas we were like i guess we could
do this
anywhere so why don't we get out of la
before it becomes an incredible coveted
hot spot
and uh get a little bit of quiet uh so
we can actually think and be productive
what do you notice about yourself or
claire
when you guys are sort of i know you're
a homebody like me you like to be home
you have to do a lot a lot of nothing
but even for me a lot of nothing became
wow i just watched the four years of the
crown in
in two days uh where you're starting to
watch
so much tv and you're like great you're
you're stalked in the fridge and
you know you're outside with your dog in
the backyard and all of a sudden you're
going
i'm with myself oh my god i can't be
with myself any longer
i mean you have each other but were were
there any times where you were like
god you're annoying me or she's like god
seth i just need to we i need to
be somewhere else yeah yeah we we
definitely took advantage of the
space at our at our house to stay
separate from each other when we needed
our own space but
i think that's that's something we
that's something we
we really try to do
even when it's not a pandemic because
we're both
such strong-willed individuals
um and then us together
you i don't know i i have to maintain
a healthy respect for her space and her
temperament and her need to be by
herself um at the same way i expect her
to be respectful of mine
so we're we're pretty good about not
getting so on top of each other that we
hate each other
but i absolutely feel you on the
i can't absorb any more media i can't
like sit and watch it i need to be
i need to get off the couch and i need
to be out in nature maybe take a hike
even if it's by myself
yeah but you're always creating things
you're always doing things and i've been
doing that too but sometimes
i've gotten to the point not right now
but like a week ago
i couldn't even sit down on my computer
and write or i get anxiety sitting there
like i can't even sit down and write
because i got anxiety and i need to get
up and i'm like what do i want to do i
need to smoke a cigarette no you don't
i need to what i mean it just it just
became this
redundant bad habit [ __ ] cycle
sorry so i feel you man that's not
that's all like really [ __ ]
tough the the thing i realized for
myself at least through this quarantine
was that i needed
to um rediscipline
in a lot of ways i'd either developed uh
bad habits
over time or worse
um coasted on my
evolution for as long as i could right
like you you make such um
any time i discovered something that
felt oh that that's gonna change the way
i do
everything um
i sort of neglected the need to
consistently
uh reinforce it right anything i've ever
been good at i got there by
rigorous consistent study and practice
and the older i've gotten the less
i feel oh i don't need to practice
right and then you shut up and start
feeling like bobby brown when
uh new edition reunited you ever see
that tape no what happened
this is amazing they're all going
through their choreography and everybody
else in the group is
[ __ ] sharp as [ __ ] like on point and
i think it was tmz or somebody they were
like yo i don't think bobby's gonna make
it on this tour
and it was a a shot of him less than a
minute of choreography
and he fell on his knees
like breathing heavy while the rest of
the band continued
the dance and i was like oh my god have
i become bobby brown i gotta get
back in the game like you don't achieve
anything without
practice without discipline right and so
especially through this pandemic
i had to and i still have to i mean i
can't act like i'm
i'm over achieving now it's like right
if you want your body to feel strong and
flexible you have to stretch and
exercise every day
you know it's true i never got anything
um
so that's the thing i've been trying to
do the most is
reignite my commitment to those
disciplines
so that i can be um
the best at what i want to be doing you
know give my best effort
you know by the way you're like you're
an actor you're a producer
writer all this some creator and you
know you think i could do this i've done
it i've done it and all of a sudden
i mean is it one of those things where
you start running lines that you haven't
got a part for just because you want to
stay fresh and you want to
think know you could memorize them you
want to know that you could do it
did you do anything like that or not
really i'm not really with that intent
but i
um i did ask my agent uh uh
like two years ago to send me auditions
and it's funny you know your agents are
like
you know you don't need to audition and
i'm like well it's not even about
the auditioning it's that i i over time
um have less a relationship uh as i did
with
casting directors and i i feel like
that's actually a really
important relationship you need casting
directors
to believe that you could play a variety
of roles
and over time i think the more
interviews i
do and the more our culture evolves
audiences
are um inclined to accept everyone as a
personality
right and the more that reality tv
becomes the vogue audiences
have a opinion about
the personalities and it's very
different from the way
you see actors right so i
always want to be seen as an actor and i
always want casting directors to
see me that way so i was like oh let me
let me just go on a bunch of auditions
let me read for some stuff that's cool
let me work out you know what i mean let
me prepare a scene
did you get any of those roles or you
just auditioned for them none of them no
did you want to um i wasn't opposed to
getting a job like i went out on each of
those things in earnest but
as as is typical with any kind of
casting you're either the thing or
you're not
right oh yeah and so with each of those
things when i looked at
who got the part i was like oh that's
just a fundamentally
different type right right we all do
it's like oh well they cast him uh
it wasn't me oh right there guys that
guy's 60 so it's funny that we were even
auditioning for the same year yeah
exactly that's true i mean do you
still get uh those those nerves before
an audition do you still get that kind
of feeling like or
are you so confident what you do that
you just do it
um i guess i just do it like i don't
have any fear about
putting in work and showing it to
somebody that's
that's kind of been my thing the whole
time um
you know as a performer that's the best
thing i can do is
is meaningfully prepare something
and then demonstrate it and then not
care
right when i leave but do you have a
rosenbomb you ever just bomb it out
in an audition yeah like you've walked
out have you ever apologized and going
i'm sorry thank you for your time
no never never uh you know what that's
not true i had a
god i had one of the worst one of the
worst experiences i ever had
auditioning tell me um it's so bad are
you ready oh
i'm ready take a drink of water i like
hearing these things
so um i met alan ball the creator
of six feet under in true blood uh back
when he was
a writer uh and a producer i think on
civil
um i auditioned for civil
10 or 12 times and i finally
got a part on the show and they had seen
me over and over like
each of the producers we met like nine
times over the course of this
and so when they finally had a part that
i could play everyone was so excited i
had the greatest time working on the
show
uh civil shepherd christine baranski
they they were
so awesome everybody was so awesome and
so
i love alan ball big allen ball fan when
american beauty uh came around i was
like
i i i chased it as hard as i could um
but you know when you see wes bentley
it's like oh i'm obviously we're very
different
types that's a very specific thing and
he was awesome in it by the way
so stayed in touch with alan
and in the last season of
six feet under they were like uh
this character is going to be recurring
against lauren ambrose
who i knew from uh
can't hardly wait real excited
going in for producers lauren's gonna be
in the room
god i can't even remember what year it
was but i had a flip phone
okay so in the early 2000s somewhere in
there
i forgot to turn my phone
before i went into this audition and
it's in my pocket and uh i was already
like
nervous because i really wanted it to go
well
i'm reading with an actor who i've got a
depth of familiarity and experience with
we should be able to
create chemistry in the way that the
scene needs and i
know this whole group i just wanted to
i just wanted to be awesome i wanted to
validate their um
faith in bringing me in at this kind of
opportunity right
like my first line my phone rings
and it's so loud
and distracting and i reach for it and
like
silence it and i just look at lauren
like oh my god
let's in my eyes i'm like okay let's
let's just stay
in this moment and she's there for me
were you blushing was your faith did
your face get red
i just immediately flopped sweat i'm
like uh carver brooks in broadcast news
like it was
i think i left a wet mark on the seat i
was sweating so hard it was one of the
worst
i've never it's i still
like i'm traumatized thinking about it
um
and then not uh 30 seconds later my
phone rings again and i'm like oh my god
oh no i silence it again very quickly
but you know
the rhythm of the scene is [ __ ] and
uh they're like do you want to start
again so i'm like okay and i'm fumbling
like trying to
turn your phone off yeah and i should
have just like took it out apologized
and shut it off but i didn't i tried to
play it cool
so we started the scene again and of
course my phone goes off again
and i did that thing that nobody wants
to do i took my phone out of my pocket
and literally
threw it into the depth of the room and
turned to apologize to everybody
and then we tried to do the scene again
of course my phone rang two more times
from the distance now jesus christ
it's on tape i'm sure i don't know if
they burn any of those tapes
did you talk to lauren afterwards and
said oh my god i'm sorry or you just
kind of let it go
i don't remember i honestly don't
remember i think i blacked out so much
of
that i don't even remember finishing the
scene or saying goodbye like i was so
embarrassed
i had to go collect my phone from the
depth of the room i got anxiety thinking
about that i i had one i think i told
this on a show a long time ago but maybe
ryan you cut it i don't remember but uh
i went in to read this guy cast me an
urban legend he cast me in pool hall
junkies sorority boys
he brought me in for this liam neeson
part and uh
movie the gray or something sure and
i went in there and i didn't know the
material and i thought i could just like
half read half do it
and i'm not kidding i go ah [ __ ] man can
we start off [ __ ]
uh you know uh john pap sadera paps can
we can we do this again
yeah he's the best and i read it and
then i go oh
man just uh you want to take a few
minutes ago yeah so it took a few
minutes then i came back
and started reading it it just was like
i could not get through it
and i go listen man finally we got
through it and he goes
thanks rosie and i go john
i really want to apologize uh i was
[ __ ] off no
no no no you you're awful still good i
go
no dude that is i mean i know how bad i
was
and uh there's no excuse for it so uh
i'm just really sorry dude i
you know you know i'm usually game and i
just wasn't and
i've had those moments i've had those
moments where a director is really into
it and then when he's really into it i'm
like
kind of like oh [ __ ] [ __ ] he likes me
and then he's giving me direction he's
like yeah yeah
all right do this i want you to do this
and then this and this and then i'm like
oh my god i'm on the verge of getting it
and then i [ __ ] up i mean that's
happened a few times i mean just but
like that's life there's sometimes where
i [ __ ] go in there and i
i kris nosh you know i guarantee that uh
john's right that even you're awful is
pretty great
uh i wouldn't say that but and you are
somebody
who is so capable of not just being
present in real life but being very
present
in scenes like you give to your work
so completely that you feel
vulnerable and stress out about
being revealed to that depth well i
never thought about you you're
so good at this you're both very very
funny
and a truly convincing actor well i mean
look
i pull your chord don't i i know i know
but like you know people don't know
people don't know seth sometimes what
goes through your mind like i could play
a role like i could go into a room and
everybody's thinking oh god this guy's
full of confidence and that but i'm not
i i could fake the [ __ ] out of it i
could go in there and kill something
but inside i'm kind of like going and
maybe it's because i care so much maybe
because i want to be great i want to
and that desire to be great that desire
to be
perfect is a is not a healthy thing to
to say hey i'm going to do my best
that's healthy but to be perfect is
impossible
did you ever do that where have you been
hard on yourself where
you know you have to be great you have
to be perfect people have to love you
you want everybody to love you and and
if you did
how do you get through that uh yes to
the first part not to the second part so
i love to be technically flawless
i love to put the work and discipline in
and then show off my
attunement to a specific skill
um but i don't um
it's not the applause and it's not the
love of the audience i i don't know how
else to explain it but that's never been
my drive like obviously i want people to
like me
but i am not um
inflated or uh benefited
by seeing my name in lights or
the size never like never been like that
ever like none of the
no none of this none of the none of the
like
it's it's a weird thing man it's in the
doing of it
for me um wow right so like
my favorite thing is really
um knowing my material so completely
that i make a
character feel like a person
so that the person connects to the
audience
and like feels the emotion
in whatever the story is so that the
audience
receives that emotion that's my favorite
my
favorite thing and it came from watching
people on stage
and watching people in commercials
convey a sentiment
to me and the audience that made me feel
any which way i was like i think that's
what i'd do
and i could and i realized it really
young you know so that's always been my
in and it's it's less about the
it is about the technical perfection of
it
the the mimicry of a character voice or
the the execution of a performance um
in a way that's so clear it it
gives it to the audience with a minimum
of words like that's
that that that's the thing that that
turns me on the most
inside of you is brought to you by
untuck it if you don't have one of these
shirts if you don't have an untucking
article of clothing i don't know what to
tell you because
these guys are fantastic i was like that
college guy who wore those
shirts that were way too long because
sometimes you want to look nice you're
were buttoned down but they were down to
your knees so people are like what is
wearing a dress
which is fine if you want to wear a
dress but i didn't want to wear a dress
at that time it was not your intention
it was not my intention to wear a dress
and uh untuck it is just phenomenal
their clothing
fits perfectly summer's here there's
never been a better time
than to try a shirt from untuck it look
at that nice shirt i'm wearing look how
it fits
snug perfect they have performance
shirts that wick sweat
also short sleeve button downs and polos
are made to beat the heat
untucked shirts are perfect as we
transition back to the things we've been
missing
dinners with friends reuniting with
family
and vacations they're perfect untuck it
makes sure it's designed to be worn
untucked they have fits for all shapes
and sizes
untuck it offers up to 3xl plus
they have slim relaxed and tall fits
untuck it has
85 stores nationwide free returns and
exchanges it's that easy you've got to
try these guys i love them you see me
wearing the shirts
use code inside for 20 off your first
purchase at untuck it that's
u n t u k
untuckit.com inside of you is brought to
you by my friends at
got pet products the family behind
charlie bear is also behind a human
ingredient company that has been
bringing expertise creative imagination
and a passion for food to people
for more than a century i love this
product i like
charlie bear and charlie bear
c-h-a-r-l-e-e
charlie bear their products their treats
my dog blanche
loves them and the hound and gatosk food
look at blanche she loves this stuff and
if you're gonna give yourself a
delicious meal
you gotta give your dog a good meal how
could you go through life
just feeding yourself with quality food
give your dog
the same and the charlie bear treats are
natural dog treats from our family to
your
best friend and they're made in the usa
they're simple
natural ingredients low calorie many
charlie bear treats only have three
calories each and they're pocket
friendly they're not going to crumble in
your pocket and make a mess
and wallet friendly ooh with high value
rewards but most importantly
your dog is going to love these treats
charlie bear look for charlie bear
products at your favorite neighborhood
pet stores and online or visit
our website at www.charliebear.com
that's c-h-a-r-l-e-e-b-e-a-r
charliebeard.com for more information
and if you love the hound and gatosk
like blanche does
let's just give another shot of blanche
eating again oh there it is go to
www.hound h-o-u-n-d
goddess g-a-t-o-s houndgatus.com
and uh inside of you is sponsored by
charlie bear
of got pet products
now that's an innate maturity that i
can't imagine you've had since the
beginning of career which started when
you were a young boy
i guess you had do you believe there's a
certain i guess this is multi-faceted
this question
wow uh but i can't believe i'm asking a
two-parter
uh but that's it oh it's heavy man but
as a kid
you always look at kid actors and
they're like always great why is that
that because they have a fearlessness to
them or whatever it is that you maybe
convey
not all kids are great but when you
watch kids performances it's almost like
they don't care and they're so
comfortable in a way at least
the ones when i think of uh sixth sense
and
you know even you as a young boy in some
roles radio days just whatever
and then then then there gets to be a
point where
i mean have you just always acted so it
never that confidence sort of never left
you or that and also
like dealing with fame and stuff does
that do you enjoy that do you enjoy
being famous
well that's a that is a lot of partners
so i grew up with a lot of kids that
wanted to perform that loved performing
and we were
the ones that sort of found each other
then there were the kids that wanted to
be
famous right and those kids usually burn
out
very fast because what it actually takes
to do this job over the course of your
life
is so much and you you you
you suffer so much heartbreak if you
actually give a [ __ ] about it
um that that becomes overwhelming and
defeating
um but my goal has always been the same
and that's helped me
stay connected even when i'm
deeply insecure about my ability to
continue to do the thing right
like i've been i've been able to
consistently work over my entire life
it's almost 40 years
of of doing this and it's it's only
through finding ways to not take it
personally
it's never about you you know what i
mean yeah finding a way to be confident
in whatever i've prepared for
an audition or a job and also
like put my heart and soul in something
and then not
care once i leave the room like that's
that's years of acquiring the discipline
and also the the simple reality man i've
seen
so many people come and go so many
people come and go
so many like from the time their kids to
the time they're adults i've seen
every version of it i've worked with
tons and tons of people
and did you call it like in the back of
your head like they're not gonna last um
i there's been times when i highlight
specific behavior and i'm like that's
probably not gonna that's probably not
that's probably gonna work against you
but um the thing that's consistent about
anybody that's stuck around
is uh hard work
being a nice person you know what i mean
um and continued
like discipline everything anybody that
stuck around has kept learning
the whole time they work really [ __ ]
hard
without asking because that's just what
you do
and then they're nice to people because
why
why not be nice to people right now we
literally play pretend
for a living yeah and so no matter how
expensive that becomes like these 200
million dollar movies that are
multi-billion dollar industries like
that's a lot of pressure to put on
anyone but
we're still doing the same job we're
putting on these costumes and we're
putting on a show
so don't don't emotionally destroy
yourself over that
it really isn't uh it's not saving the
world the same way
right you make that sound so simple but
really
the two things are hard work and being a
good person being a kind person those
those are the main things if you work
really hard and you have
your talent and you're nice to people
you're probably gonna work if you're an
[ __ ] and you're not great
people will find someone else yeah if
you're successful people will tolerate
a remarkable uh amount of bad behavior
but i think we're becoming less tolerant
of it i think
it really feels like the industry over
the last several years has
had a highly reflective moment and has
worked to alter itself
you know yeah through every facet i'm
optimistic
what about being famous is there
obviously there's pluses i mean
you know i i love getting free [ __ ] i
love
you know being invited to lucas ranch i
love being you know
god bless i mean there's things i've
done that were just dreams to me as a
kid and still our dreams that i'm
fulfilling
and uh i love that but with fame
obviously
it's not always easy people like oh poor
guy he did this and everything you do is
scrutinized and
um i mean do you enjoy the fame or do
you like
uh i'm obviously you're an incredibly
kind person i've met you i've never seen
you raise your voice to anyone i've
always seen people come up to you and
you just sign autographs and you're fine
but uh do you get tired of it
um well i'm i'm someone that actually
likes to
spend time by myself so that's
compromised um a degree of anonymity
that i enjoyed without realizing that it
was
a perk but um there's definitely pluses
right
like there's things that i get to do
because people recognize my face
or have a um a predetermined opinion of
me
even before we meet so it makes our
encounter
far more positive than their average
encounter with
any other person like i get an instant
icebreaker which is very helpful
in conversations i wouldn't say i'm
socially awkward but i'm not
um i've definitely spent my life
overcoming all those basic social fears
right uh
and so being recognizable helps shortcut
a little bit of that and it also gives
me a bit of a magic power
um in conversations to make people
smile or laugh which is one of my
favorite things to do me too
sure yeah you know downsides are that
you can't really have a good day uh
that's already slipped let me let me
let me say it like this i heard um
got in an interview in the late 90s uh
pep from sultan peppa she said the
hardest part about being famous is you
can't have a public bad day
right because the millionth time
you meet an excited fan is the only time
that fan meets you wow and so
what do you want that moment to be i
think about that all the time like i
don't need to let it
dominate i when i when i first started
getting recognized i really
i couldn't help myself but to cater to
it i felt such an incredible
responsibility to make that person's
experience so significant that i would
neglect my actual friends or family
that i was in the middle of hanging out
with and i had people
people became so bold man like i was in
the middle of slow dancing with a
girlfriend on a beach
and somebody literally got between us
and put their hands on either of our
shoulders and was like yo can we take a
picture
jeez i became a stall man in the
bathroom
because so many [ __ ] creepers when
the camera phone
became invented by world james and when
someone like puts their phone above your
toilet style you're like what what do
you want out of this
they want to see poop maybe
i had that once i was in a i was at a
concert
not too long ago i think it was chicago
or something i was seeing the band
chicago
uh they're still around and uh you know
we're i'm in there and the guy goes
he looks at me goes i know you man i'm
like
yeah what's going on he's like yeah man
could we get a picture i go hey can we
have a conversation
after i'm done holding my dick and he's
like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah and it was cool but it
was just like i mean i am holding my
penis urinating in a stall
can you wait a minute i could
but it would be it wouldn't be as good a
story it would be as good a store as
next loser was holding his dick
look at this picture of us with our
dicks this is great
why does it always go back to that
accent i grew up in indiana
it always goes man tell me so i can't be
like i was looking at lex luthor's dick
see we could flip the script right now
and become a more woke hollywood if we
just started doing
less derisive impersonations
i think so i think that's going to
happen i think that's slowly going to
happen
oh i love it but you are you are a good
guy and i think that goes a long way do
you ever watch yourself and go
oof i'm not good in that have you ever
done this as an actor
yeah oh my god yeah what role did you
watch
that maybe people really liked that you
didn't like what you did
i'm not gonna point that out like that's
one thing i learned early on is let the
audience have their own experience
what is something you watch and go i did
my job there
i thought i was uh decent thought i did
a good job um
well there's a couple there's a couple
performance opportunities that i've had
that i love
and i and i did
the thing that um felt the best to me
which was like
be in it be in it so much and
be technically um efficient to a degree
that it yields
the right emotion the right lap right
like i was
um awesome powers is one of my
favorite things because i was just
rooted in that character and i was
um liberated at
every channel to improvise and just
follow a laugh
but in character that something
so magical happened when we were making
those movies
and that's why we got to make three of
them because everybody felt it
from from from the people making it to
the audience
i got something something cool is
happening here everybody was just
in it and firing on all cylinders so
that feels amazing um i felt like
um i can't hardly wait i
was so present and it's it's that thing
man
i worked so hard on that
like i knew my lines backwards and
forwards i spent
so much time thinking about who that
character was
and why why i was behaving the way that
i was
why i said the things that i said from
scene to scene
and by the time we and plus uh devin
harry were so
great directing that and the the cast we
got like
lauren and i we worked we worked
hard on all of those scenes
and and then every day every day i woke
up and i
exercised and i drove to um
uh what the [ __ ] it called valencia
um and i listened to
the rap music that i was convinced kenny
fisher spent every day listening to you
on my drive
and i just knew it and i felt it and i
like tried to get into this
i was so into it so i feel like you can
see that you can see that in the
in the performance that's not right same
thing with party monster
but it was the work right like it's
never not the work
there's never like oh my god one of the
best things i did i didn't even know the
[ __ ] lines and i'd never read the
script and i just showed up and
improv because i'm so talented that i
could just show up and do it
right it's never though it's i love that
it's always the stuff where you're like
oh my god
i studied that i looked at the me i like
practiced i rehearsed i did this
this blocking over and over and over and
over so many times
that i got a blister on my foot it's
those it's right always that word oh my
god that felt
the best again it's the work it's the
work you got
hard work you know seth macfarlane said
when i mean it's not busting concrete
but you know
okay sometimes it feels like a different
kind of work
sets you through the emotional rigor
seth mcfarlane said
in the audition for uh family guy you
were off the rails he says
when you know when you go in for an
audition sometimes 99 of the time
you think this is what it reads as this
is what it is
this is uh i'm the whatever the
the stone guy or the surfer kid or
whatever it is and i'm going to read it
like oh
they want to surfer so i'll be like oh
hey man what's going on brah
oh they want a stoner guy it's like
and so you go in what was it like going
in
for family guy what was going through
your mind um
i had been digging around
with charlie corso for over a week
doing an impersonation of ted levine
from
uh silence of the lambs right right
right charlie came into town
to do the press drum kit for can't
hardly wait
and we spent the week um they sent
us all of the clippings right like
they're like hey here's all the press
points you got and it was at the time
for a copied pronounce
with all of our reviews i don't know if
you know this
the reviews of that movie were not kind
and they singled out each of the actors
individually and
in more than ten
just attacked our physical aesthetic oh
so charlie and i were like all right we
had just done
not a mean-spirited press junket but you
know a lot of people are like why did
you make this
and so you i got to the point where we
weren't even defensive we were just like
let's just have fun with this
we were highlighting every um
category of insult and then just sort of
walking each other
through the ptsd oh my god and um
he stayed with me and i don't even know
how we got off on the topic but we just
started talking about the character from
silence and the lambs
getting odd jobs and doing everything
from
being a roller rink dj which i love to
trying to order something at jack in the
box because that
his character's so specific and he
does this really dark kind of thing
oh wait a minute
[Laughter]
was she a great big fan person
i've been doing that impression for
years too i just i'm enamored by that
guy
and i finally worked with him and i'm
like hey he's like oh good how are you
i'm like holy [ __ ] you talk like that
he's a brilliant actor oh yeah
performance is incredible uh but that
character is so indelible that we just
joked around putting like mimicking the
whole thing and so
i read that script for family guy and i
loved it i wanted it you know what i
mean it was so
funny i was like ah this will never last
on tv but let me be a part of it
and so i i came in and i did the like
what's up dodge
fight the machine and did the whole
surfer thing and i was like can i this
may be stupid but can i try something
you know what i mean and it's always
that it's always the risk that you take
it's always the i got i got a lot of
jobs that
didn't read um from a stage
uh uh stage direction standpoint as me
right i'm 5'4 i'm redheaded i'm very
pale
and i'm not what you call conventionally
attractive
but i have a lot of personality right
and that's always that's always kept me
going so i like to try [ __ ] you know
most casting people
it's like they want something specific
but what they
really notice is somebody that shines
and you never shine doing it the way
oh it it organically reads this way
right you gotta add something the actors
that
we both love they're just they're in it
they make choices and they just they
they just they're disciplined with it
so you and it's like not everybody's
walking right not everybody's like got
the bits
right but you so you said i want to try
something was this the last thing you
were going to do before you were done
with the audition
i didn't even know i was going to do it
i honestly didn't even i think course
mode dared me to at one point he was
like
you should do a buffalo bill like what
if he was buffalo
what if what if what if buffalo bill's
day job was being
this family's kid
[Laughter]
hey dad
yeah dad i'm really glad you got fired
from your
job way to take care of us hey dad i got
paddled in school today i'm
pretty sure yeah
i put my pants so what'd you do in the
audition what did you say
it was a lie i said uh hey can i try
something um
my buddy and i have spent all week
with buffalo bill from silence and i
remember mcfarland was like
uh yeah and then i was like
what if i did that and then i just tried
it
and it was so [ __ ] weird that i think
it made everybody laugh and i thought
i'm never going to get this job
and then i got it and i was like there's
there really is like a magic universe
so wait so you did you did he asked you
to do okay do that but can you do a
little less of the
or can you do a little more of a kid
doing buffalo but it's a younger yeah is
there a younger version of it
and i'm just sort of pitching it up a
little bit
but it didn't the whole first like the
whole first season of it
it's really down there it's really low
where it's just like
uh um
pretty sure i got her business card
everywhere like it's
really
that's amazing that's one of the best
hollywood stories ever
the fact that they're like oh yeah that
and it works you watch the character and
you're like this is perfect well it's
evolved really far from that
although we have done some homages to it
in the uh
in the 20 seasons on the air
inside of you is brought to you by
echelon i'll tell you ryan
i've been working out uh not very much
and i've been working a lot and that's
not good
because where does the stress go nowhere
it goes nowhere that's the problem and
echelon
it makes it so easy to work out i love
these guys
i've wanted to get in in shape but i
don't have time to go to the gym so
i bring the gym home i've got this
amazing mirror where i could press one
button
and i'm at a boxing class another button
and i'm stretching i'm riding the
echelon bike i'm doing the rower i'm
doing everything i could do at the gym
at my house and when you're trying to
reach your fitness goals it's important
it can really help to have instructors
like nicole griffin and michael brown
alongside a community of 25 000 members
who can give you that extra push that
extra push
echelon gives you that echelon is the
affordable way to get the workout
equipment
the workout community and an
instructor's motivation
right at the comfort of your own home
echelon's fitness app provides you
thousands of live and on-demand classes
with great music from your favorite
artists with echelon you can work out
any time
day or night and crush your fitness
goals crush it just pick your class
climb the leaderboard cheer each other
on and give it your all
track your workouts and progress to each
of your fitness goals
yes and what's great is a full range of
affordable workout equipment guys
stationary bikes smart rowers sleek
fitness screens or the auto folding
treadmill
all connected with the echelon
experience around the clock classes for
the family
including full-body workout programs
that keep you coming back
for more and more our membership one
membership
covers a family of five and now
listeners will get a special podcast
offer from echelon that's right
ryan for a limited time only start your
30-day risk-free trial offer with
echelon's ex-3 bike for just
one dollar a special risk-free offer for
30 days with echelon's ex3 bike for only
one dollar to start
plus free shipping the only way to get
this special offer is by going to
echelonfit.com
inside that's e c h e l
o n f i t dot com
slash inside echelon fit dot com
slash inside get it going guys it's that
easy
inside of you is brought to you by geico
i'll tell you what geico man these
people are everywhere geico you know why
because they're good they're good at
what they do and everybody knows geico
and you know uh we've talked about this
a million times but
look i'm lazy as hell and i don't want
to pay my
auto policy and my renter's policy and
my homeowner's policy to different
people and write different checks and
geico just makes it freaking easy man it
just makes it easy with geico's bundling
policy
so you can just do it all in one batch
it's geico easy it's good because we're
so busy ryan we get
we get you know you got the the your
parents new puppy that you have to go
visit every once in a while
yeah maybe sooner than later yeah i mean
i i've got stuff going on
we don't have time for this let's just
do things that are easy in our life
we get a great rate it's geico go
to geico.com get a quote and see how
much you can save it's geico easy
visit geico.com today that's geico.com
robot chicken are you coming back for an
11th yes we're actually
uh are we shooting it we've written the
whole thing
we've got a half hour special that
hasn't been announced yet that i'm
incredibly excited about
um and then uh
and then yes a whole 11th season is on
the way
well thanks for having me on by the way
that was a dream and i'm so glad you got
you had me on that was so funny i was
super confused that you that you'd only
done it the one time
yeah i think i think overall this time
i've just assumed everybody has done it
so i'm always surprised when especially
a friend of mine is like hey why haven't
you ever
had me on the show and i'm like not on
purpose i don't know if i said that i
just said hey if you ever need me on
here's what happened i go hey if you
ever need a voice anything on robot
chicken you go
wait you haven't been on it i go no he
goes he goes yeah you'll get on it and i
immediately called our castle and i was
like please put rosenbaum on for
whatever
comes up that was that's worth his time
oh
i would have done one line i would have
done i would have just yelled
hey i don't love that i love when people
come in and get to do something that's
why that's why we have everybody do
three parts well this new show blark and
sun on comedy series on comedy central
yeah
yeah dude i like i in an interview you
said this is like
you know it's the weirdest thing you've
done or maybe you put on instagram
and then i go okay let's see if how
weird seth's talking and then i watch it
i go whoa
this is fun i felt like i was watching
that phil
collins video in this all the world we
live in it was so it's
i love it yeah i love them
the junior characters just
they can't the you guys have to see this
on comedy central it is
so bizarre that i mean who came up with
this that's all
uh ben bay youth the um uh this is this
is something i
i haven't had to it sounds silly i
haven't had to do anything
for this except consistently affirm that
it's a good idea
right so very very early on it's years
ago now
ben um wanted to produce
they showed us the puppets first and he
was like this is a thing
and then i can't even remember if you've
filmed the demo or not
but they were gonna do it on instagram
and just just make it and so
we financed that and then it got picked
up from
instagram to be um do you remember when
verizon
had a platform for a second so go 90
came after us and was like we'll finance
uh a run of shorts and so we produced a
series of shorts for
them and then that whole thing went out
of business
and we got the rights back and sold it
to comedy
um to make an online series that also
rears on the network and i i
again i just think the thing is so
[ __ ] funny it's so creative
it's so strange it's full of incredible
performers
and unbelievable production value um
it is by far the weirdest thing
it's so weird it's so you can't stop
watching it that's how weird it is you
can't stop watching these characters
like oh
these characters are so larger than life
that i'm just like going oh my god
i gotta keep watching this if you go to
the instagram page i might get high and
watch
that that they filmed it's it's just
very very funny
and smart and really capture something
about um
family dynamics and then you know
neighborhood dynamics
um and the biggest thing is i love all
that
tech right because it's the exact same
stuff that you would use to make a
monster movie right so if you're gonna
make american werewolf in london it's
the same
principle it's all the same machines and
materials and stuff
so i've been i've been trying to fortify
that department of our studio
so that we can render visual effects for
um something that a future i want to
make wow and you have all the tools it's
like you have the studio you have this
it's like a smorgasbord of uh just i i
mean
you have so many ideas and you have the
ability to
pursue these ideas in an easier way when
it comes to that sort of uh
platform right well i mean it's always
hanging on by a thread
right everything is always sort of on a
thread um
because you're you talk about the
consistent employment of hundreds of
people
um and so there's a lot of management
involved
in that like um like that whole
department that i'm talking about
um they've been doing the uh masks for
the masked singer for the last
two seasons and um the same the same
shop essentially that does blarken sun
oh hey say hello
claire how are you i'm good i hope y'all
are having fun
we are we love you i miss you i can't
wait till this is over so we can hug it
out
i know i know i'm going to hustle
so good i'm going to hug this [ __ ] out
of you like honestly a long hugger like
he wasn't kidding
it's gonna be a long hard hug the long
and hard hug
uh man that's awesome i love that you
get to do that but you're talking about
the mask
singer and the uh oh yeah so
but you know what it's like that uh with
that department it's only as big as it
needs to be but the idea is that you can
grow and shrink some some things um and
it's all the same
it's all the same technology hey uh the
episode it aired right we're on family
guy or seth green versus seth macfarlane
where you're playing
right but the characters are talking at
each other i saw that online but was
that interesting
yeah that started um explain the
situation how it started
well it it started as something
like genuinely unbelievable that both
family guy
and robot chicken were um
working with lucasfilm to make uh
dedicated episodes uh for star wars
um and so seth macfarlane and i who have
known each other
since um 98 and um
we were commiserating backstage at one
of the panels where we were going to go
talk at this family guy panel
to talk about the star wars thing and we
were both like
this is the coolest thing ever we're
making star wars specials for
our respective shows that's it's nuts
it's nuts nuts and um we were making
them at the exact
same time and writing them at the same
time which was actually such a benefit
because i could call their writer's room
and say hey we're doing a cantina joke
that's shaped like this what's your
cantina joke
oh we're doing a trash compactor joke
that's shaped like this what's your
trash compactor joke
and it's in a couple cases we were in
the same territory
and were able to keep our uh stuff um
um separate so that we weren't
overlapping each other
in a specific joke or a specific idea
and
it was i it was [ __ ] awesome man and
so
um just because of the nature of
production we
robot chicken beat family guy to air
and aired first and um after we had i
think it was even after we'd done
we were in the middle of pickups so they
had started rendering animation for the
family guy one
and i came in to do a set of pickups and
that scene
which is not a post-credit tag but it's
like the end of it
has chris talking to peter
about um well dad that was very exciting
but you know technically robot chicken
did it first
and then peter's like ah yeah but you
know chris that's not a uh real
show on a real pro a real network and it
is
it's so mean and also really disparaging
of me
and the robot chicken but it's also very
very funny and in the context he sort of
cops to the fact that
we aired first even though like millions
of
less people saw it and it just i don't
know none of us really cares but it went
back and forth
right so it went back and they did it in
all three in all three of the um
uh family guy specials and they start
getting like far
more specifically targeted against me
seth green as an
actor yeah what would they say what was
one of the
i don't remember it was just that they
made fun of movies i've done but it also
you know it is funny and i just don't
care
uh it was so funny people enjoy the fact
that we all know each other
oh man but it's good you're in good
spirits you both can go at it and have
fun with it well i
i you know some of my favorite stuff is
the
is the friar's roasts is um old episodes
of the match game
yeah i think people i think that's why
twitter worked in the first place is
because people
enjoy conversations amongst
any artists that they are interested in
right uh this is called [ __ ] talking
with seth green [ __ ] talking with seth
green
uh some [ __ ] talking some [ __ ] with my
patrons if you want to join patreon you
should it's awesome
uh this is rapid fire steph a how much
of your entourage persona
is you and how much is exaggerated
that's 100 exaggerated
brandel what is the most challenging
voice impression
that you can do i think the hardest
stuff for me to do is like
really really high-end things like from
i mean like trying to do a baby crying
or
or something that's a lot of screaming
like oh my god i've had to do
um death eaters for harry potter
sketches
and that's that's really not fun do you
lose your voice
no it's sort of a backwards breathing
thing where you're like
i'm coming to kill you
the crazy [ __ ] you get to do yeah
uh leanne p of all the characters you've
played which one do you identify with
the most um no i mean i find something
in
every character that that feels organic
deflection i'm just kidding this is the
truth
i mean i i really do if i'm if i'm
interested in playing a character it's
because i feel like i can give them an
honesty
and so there's got to be something in
them that i identify too even if it's
not
decision-making that i'd relate to right
like your character makes decisions
sometimes that you as a person can't
relate to
and so you gotta find some organic way
to come to that conclusion
or you just can't be honest in your
performance i like
it little lisa i do that's a good answer
little lisa what's something you can't
go a day without doing besides seeing
your wife
um i don't know i think i like to think
i'm
fairly adaptable deflection
no i'm kidding it's the truth i don't um
i don't
love um addictions um
i don't i don't like bad habits
um but i also
haven't been dependent on any specific
thing
to get through a day right and since
i've spent my whole life
working in unpredictable conditions and
still having to render a very specific
service regardless i've i've
i like to think i've become adaptable
and i don't i don't need much
aisha says you were almost cast as jay
and mall rats
can you talk about what the process was
and what happened
i don't think it's accurate to say that
i was almost cast as j.m rats there was
really no
i don't think there was ever a point
where anybody took seriously the idea of
jason muse not playing that part
um and the process was um
uh we got called because
uh uh it's not don simpson and it's not
do you remember god damn it i can't
believe i'm i'm blind
no no no no it was the the casting
director and his first name is don and
he had cast
uh daze and confused and the way that
they had done that was they basically
had a chemistry party
over a day and got a bunch of pizzas and
got a bunch of actors
and had them all workshop scenes
together and then they
selected who they thought looked the
best on camera and had the best
chemistry and so when
the same casting director was casting
mall rats
he employed the same idea where
dozens of actors um it was so many
people it's crazy
and each of us came in and out of the
room
being paired up in a variety of places
um
and i
when i found out that because jason was
there
we were all in the same hallway for like
11 hours as they paired us up in groups
and went in
in all different varieties of the group
and i
already felt dumb about
trying to be jay when
jason muse was in the running for jay
it's like i know so it felt so
futile in the first place and i also
wanted to really distinguish my
take on jay from what jason had done in
clerks
but at the same time it's written out
snooty booches
and you're you're like how do i read
this line
without it right i mean god
yeah you know like like a like a j like
a j
rip off so um you know the process was
harrowing
i just chased laughs the entire time
i just i just peacocked all around
because that that was
the spirit of that character for me was
it just
unapologetically loud and takes up space
right so that's fun um because i'm not a
big guy so taking up a lot of space
you know it's why kevin hart's so
popular is because he's an enormous
personality
right right so that's what i did but
it wasn't fun jimmy ross did tim curry
scare you to death while filming it
no i was such a tim curry fan
when i got that job that i was in awe of
him
um as a student is to a master
and i started at speed and asked him
questions all the time
and i just followed his lead on process
it was so [ __ ] exciting to get to
spend time with him
to get to work with him i mean
it really was um especially him
like i loved him so much and his roles
and performances meant
so much to me by the time we got to work
together that i was not gonna fail
you know what i mean yeah i wasn't gonna
fail i worked so hard
to be prepared for every scene and that
in that one too
wow karen b
last question what are some of your best
memories of working
with robin williams wait i have to i
feel like i have to follow up on that
just one more time oh yeah no go
well because it was so cool that we
stayed in touch
um after working together and he was
just incredibly kind and generous
in ways that few people are um so even
beyond getting to work together i just
love that man that's a beautiful thing
so what was it like in your best
memories of working with robin williams
and old dog
i mean that whole thing was really fun
and special for me
um we'd met um
before but not not like that
um and the first day that we got to work
together was a scene
with a lot of improv potential in it and
we just had a great time i was like
whatever you
give me i'm gonna send it back to you
and uh
you know what i mean as it was just like
electric wow
and then throughout the rest of making
that movie we we went back at one point
and
uh got a bunch of scenes they they
totally changed the ending
um and we shot a bunch of pickup stuff
and even that was just hilarious it's
just so much fun
um
you know he's truly one of my heroes
um getting to know him even
peripherally um and getting to work with
him is
like one of my proudest things
did you ever notice anything because you
know he's always the happy guy i always
i can relate where i you know i go not
to robin williams obviously he's
brilliant i'm just saying in terms of
like always being the center of
attention i always felt like as a kid
i've always
i felt like that was the only way i
could get in and and
you know it was did you feel like did
you ever see the real side of him did
you think did you ever
see a innate sort of sadness or anything
like that or was it always just kind of
fun and
fun and uh you know good times no we i
got i got to spend a couple of really
quiet moments with him and i was i was
even grateful for that we we did an
extensive amount of press
for that movie including like a whole um
golden globe uh a series of
interviews with the farm press and i i
was just with him
that whole day and it was a long day
and we um
had lunch together in his room
um and really we're just quiet
like just sat in the quiet because it
had been so noisy it had been so chaotic
and i took his comfort in
not needing to perform for me um
and me not needing to entertain him
yeah you know i didn't know that he was
sick
and he didn't let on that he was
struggling
with um his interpretation of things
um but i did see him in between
scenes right so like when
uh uh lillard and dax and i were working
together
in between scenes we were just like
you know what i mean right keeping that
five and robin in between
scenes would just go sit in a quiet
corner and play
sudoku
sudoku sudoku just like
brain challenges brain challenges just
brain challenge
video game brain challenges and we
talked a lot about comics and video
games and he
he just graciously consumed stuff
wow but i didn't realize in that time
that he was
struggling with cognition
with interpretation with uh even basic
motor function
and nobody knew nobody knew until after
and uh
you know i had bobcat on the show a
while back and he talked about it
because he was close friends with him
and they
he opened up a little bit about that and
uh
it's tragic it's like i think a lot of
people that we know we always see this
fun
loving hey how are you but we don't
really know what they're going through
or what they do when they go home or
what
you know kind of like the the clown with
the painted face and the painted smile
and sometimes we we don't know exactly
and so
you know i have a you know on this show
i always talk about
mental health and you know you never
know what other people are going through
and so
it's just important to to try and just
like you said
be kind be nice and i didn't i didn't
originate that philosophy but i know
you didn't i think henry winkler did i
think henry winkler originated that the
nice he's
he's one of the kindest he really is
that man he is he's super well dude
this i don't want to take any more time
this is this has been great yeah
it's such a chore to catch up with you
michael it's such a true
god we need this podcast to stay friends
what if i wrote you an email after this
and said hey
i really didn't even want to interview i
i just needed you i needed to talk to
you i just wanted to hear your voice
i thought for sure that's what this was
but it's just kind of a podcast format
that makes it much easier to open up to
each other
you know what though it is nice to just
you know to
friends to talk and open up and uh
hopefully give back to some of the
people that are listening that you know
listen to the show or or fans of yours
or whatever
and uh you know it's important to me and
after this i just
i just feel like i got a lot from it and
uh so thank you
me too man and you know everybody
everybody
struggles with that imposter syndrome
everybody doubts themselves and any
artist that is
like really compelled
to create is forced to ask
who gives a [ __ ] about anything that i'm
making and you just
can't let that stuff guide you
you know you've got too big a heart to
get in your own way thank you my friend
no i appreciate that and uh so i'll just
write you a check or venmo you after
nah man but i'm gonna cash it in your
ass next time i see you
give me the lt atm swipe of the ass
buddy
dude i love you seth this has been great
though thank you so much
love seth green what can you say about
him other than he's a great guy thank
you for listening
and i hope you enjoyed that if you
enjoyed it again please subscribe to the
podcast and stick around for other
guests that are coming up
uh we've got a lot of great guests and a
lot of guests from the past you know
we had jason patrick and keith for
sutherland charisma carpenter from buffy
um bob odenkirk many great guests so
please write a review and uh remember
the handles if you want to follow us are
at inside you podcast on instagram and
facebook at insideepod on the
twitter and uh you can watch us on
youtube also you can watch these videos
ryan you do a great job editing
[Music]
also if you want to join patreon my
patreon family there's tears
and patrons great because if you like
the podcast you want to give a little
bit
more to the podcast you could join
patreon.com inside of you i write you a
message
right after you join thanking you and
there's a lot of tiers with a lot of
great added bonus material and bonus
stuff that you can get uh which is
pretty
awesome at the end of this uh episode
we're gonna read out the uh patrons like
i always do the top tiers get a shout
out
that's what they get i'd like to let you
guys know that i'm going to be
uh in lexington uh actually first i'm
gonna be in houston at a
uh comic palooza july 17th wow so i'm
gonna be rocking signing autographs
doing a bunch of stuff so if you're in
houston
go to comapalooza.com or whatever you'll
find it
uh you could probably look on my uh my
handles you know all that stuff
at michael rose rosenbaum on twitter
the michael rosenbaum on the instagram
and facebook
um and other cons coming down the road
september 4th dragoncon i'll be in
atlanta i'll be in lexington september
9th through the 12th
uh for that weekend for the comic
convention and uh september 24th west
virginia
also the band um we are going to be
playing
on stage it if you go to stage at dot
com actually you could just go to
sunspin.com the band is sunspin
we're gonna be playing two shows two 2
p.m and 6 p.m july 31st
saturday july 31st so get your tickets
it's gonna be a great show
covers and uh we're gonna play some of
the album and uh
it's gonna be a lot of fun also if you
want any sun spin merch
band merch go to sunspin.com you could
book the band you could uh
zoom with me also the inside of you
online store if you want any inside of
you
uh merch we've got uh tons of stuff
new mugs um shirts
lex luthor shirts lunch boxes small the
lunch boxes
uh funko pops i'll sign them so you know
them they're for me
because i see a lot of people signing
ryan you know there's there's people
that are selling my stuff and
like why don't at least they'll know
it's for me yeah so
that real deal it's the real deal do you
have a good week man are you
is your stress are you a little better i
know you're doing some therapy no it's
good i mean honestly
i just got back from visiting my parents
and that was a really nice thing to do
uh you get along with your parents i get
along with mike you like being around
your parents like
my parents i play guitar with my dad oh
man
it's beautiful i like hanging over my
mom they got a new puppy what's the
puppy's name
blue blue attaboy blue she's uh
12 weeks old she's gonna be huge
cute as a button cute as a button she
doesn't know how her body works it's
really adorable
that's that's it's always a treat
watching that watching them grow and
then yeah
especially when you get them at a young
age and you just love them more as they
get older and older they just they're
always that puppy we've never had a
puppy growing up this is the first pup
well congratulations on that
congratulations to you going to therapy
i think that's marvelous yeah
hopefully you guys are all doing well
taking care of yourself doing therapy if
you need it
i think we all probably need it i know i
do thanks for listening thanks for uh
tuning in
uh i just had a surgery uh everything's
going well
um i am i am alive and
uh you know it takes time to heal but uh
it's it's it's gonna it's gonna work out
in the end
i think we should probably read out the
uh the top tier patrons
i think that's a marvelous plan you know
before we do that i want to read you a
little uh i read you a little letter
here
this is from a fan this is from a
listener more importantly petra
hey michael really enjoyed the unique
style of your podcast with their mental
health life lessons perspective
i showed up originally as a smallville
fan who enjoyed your portrayal of lex
luthor better than gene hackman in my
opinion with more depth and nuance
thank you petra i began re-watching
recently as a way of escaping the
pandemic i look forward to seeing you in
some new movies or series after the
current situation is over i have the
feeling you would be amazing in a film
noir role anyway best of luck with sun
spin the band and a happy
new year petra just thought that was
nice just reading you know little
little blurbs you like hearing that
you're better than gene hackman too well
maybe that's why i read it well
i mean it doesn't suck all right here
are the top tier patrons if you join
patreon go to patreon.com
inside you i read a message uh i'll read
your message and i'll and i'll
send you a message for joining and
thanking you and uh it's a lot of fun if
you want to help the podcast in any
other way
uh these are the big shout outs nancy d
mary b
leah s tricia f sarah v little lisa
yukiko jill e bryan h lauren g
nico robin s jerry w robert b
jason w apothean kristen k amelia o
allison l lucas m
we got raj c joshua d emily s
cj p yes we do samantha m jennifer n
stacy l carly h carly s jen s jamal f
janelle b tabitha 272 nothing to be
confused with time with the 273
kimberly e mikey l don supremo 99 more
ramirez santiago m
sarah f chad w leanne p ray a maya p
maddie s
kendrick ashley e ashley e shannon d
matt w
belinda n kevin v james r chris h dave
h samantha s spider-man chase sheila
g correct ray h tabitha t see i just
want to keep him on his toes folks
tab of the t tom and suzanne b lilliana
a
michelle k marcus w hannah b mish
michael s talia m
andrew t betsy oh claire claire she did
it on adair claire
liz j laura l chad l rochelle nate uh
rochelle
nathan e i'm one of those guys who
sometimes
has to lick their lips because of the
papers otherwise i can't get them do you
ever do that
i think i'm gonna have to start doing
that at some point is it an age thing
no i've been doing it for years and my
friends make fun of me
taylor k marion meg k janelle p trav
l dan and diane r ah jeddah
lorraine g corey m veronica k big stevie
w
kendall t carol d sandy b angel m eric c
ray nc
uh steven m cory case super sam emily c
sherry s coleman g david c michelle a
matt w
liz l jeremy c andy t cody
r chris e sebastian k gavinator and
h elliott m and john b thank you
guys uh for subscribing to the podcast
giving extra the podcast you patrons
rule
um and uh ryan they like you on the q
and a's
ryan sometimes helps me with the q and
a's and uh unfortunately for you ryan
they like you which means hopefully
you'll do it again i hate being liked
i hate being liked it just really sucks
anyway uh i appreciate you guys
listening to the show
and uh please tell everybody you know
and write an email
and get folks to listen and i love doing
this and i love you guys
thank you for allowing me to be inside
of each and every one of you
from myself michael rosenbaum and myself
give him a wave over at the big camera
up there bye we love you guys
thanks so much
[Music]